ازمه الطاقه العالميه وارتفاعه الاسعار في
الولايات المتحده يدفعني واشنطن للبحث عن
طرق تثبيت السعر محليا صحيفه بوليتيكو
الامريكيه افادت بان الولايات المتحده
تضغط على الاتحاد الاوروبي كتله وعدد وله
بشكل منفرد لفرد سقفا لسعر النفط الروسي
اضافت صحيفه نقلا عن دبلوماسي اوروبي قوله
ان الضغط الامريكي نحو تبني السقف السعر
المفروض يشمل الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
ينطبق على المستوى الداخلي الامريكي
الديبلوماسيه يعتبر ان المصالح الاوروبيه
الحيويه على المحك وانه يتعين على دول
الاتحاد ان تتوقف عن معاقبه نفسها على
حساب روسيا اشارت بولتيكو الى ان الاتحاد
فشله في تحديد سقف لسعر نفط الروسي
الاسبوع الماضي بعد ما اقترحت المفوضيه
الاوروبيه تحديدا سقفا اقصى لسعر البرميل
يتراوح بين
65$ المقترح هذا قبل بم كل من بولندا دول
البطيخ اليونان مالطا وقبرص التي تفضل رفع
سقف السعر او التوصل لالي التعويض لهذه
الدول التي تعتمد على حركه الناقله
النفطيه قبل ذلك كان وزراء ماليه مجموعه
السبع اعلنوا عزمهم عن فرض سقفا لسعر
النفط الروسي عبر انشاء تحالف دولي يحضر
تقديم اي خدمات للنقل البحري لن نفطر روسي
في حال بيع النفط بسعر اعلى من الحد
المتفق عليه من قبل هذا التحالف ومن
المتوقع ان يدخل هذا القرار حيز التنفيذ
في الخامس من ديسمبر المقبل
[موسيقى]
محاولات واشنطن خفض اسعار الوقود على
المواطنين الامريكيين دفع الاداره للنظر
جنوبا نحو دوله ربما غير متوقع فنزويلا
بسبب العلاقات
على كاهل الرئيس
شركه النفط العملاقه لانتاج وتصدير النفط
من فنزويلا بعد قرار كراكس نافع المحادثات
مع جماعه المعارضه في العاصمه المكسيكيه
ولتيكو نقلت عن مسؤول في الاداره قوله ان
تخفيف العقوبات غير مرتبط سوق النفط
وارجعه فقط
السير على طريق السعاده الديمقراطيه في
البلاد بحسب قول المسؤول الامريكي القرار
الامريكي ياتي ايضا قبل الموعد النهائي
تشديد العقوبات على روسيا في الخامس من
ديسمبر والتي يمكن ان يعكر صفوه اسواق
النفط العالميه بموجب الترخيص الصادر عن
الخزانه الامريكيه يحضر على شركه النفط
البنزويليه الحكوميه تلقي ارباح من مبيعات
النفط الناتجه عن مشروعها المشترك مع شركه
شيفرون لكن رغم التصريح الامريكي من غير
المحتمل ان يصل المزيد من النفط الفانزلي
الى الاسواق قريبا قبل ضخ النفط في
فنزويلا يتعين على شركه شارون اصلاح
المعدلات المعطله واعاده توظيف مئات
العمال مع تزايد الهجره
لمواجهه الانقطاعات في الكهرباء وتهديدات
الامنيه بما في ذلك سرقه البنزين ايضا
ستواجه مشكله فنيه جمع في حقول النفط
المتقدمه في فنزويلا وشبكه معقده من
العقوبات الامريكيه المتبقيه التي يجب
تغييرها لضمان وصول المزيد من النفط
الفنزلي بالاسواق عالميه يصبح هناك مشكله
كبيره في الحقول عندما لا يتم الانتاج
بشكل دائم كما تعلمون بوليتيكول التقت
بخبراء في القطاع النفطيه من فنزويلا
واتفقوا على ان حجم الاموال اللازمه
للاستثمار في البلاد لاستعاده الانتاج
المفقود قد يصل الى 50 مليار دولار رقم
مهول كما ان شركه شيفرون قد تتمكن من
اضافه ما يصل الى 30,000 برميل نفط يوميا
الى الانتاج خلال الاشهر السته المقبله
وهو رقم اقل من ان يحدث اي فرق في السوق
العالميه بوليتك واضافت انه على الرغم من
ان فنزويلا تملكه اكبر احتياطيه في العالم
الا ان الامر قد يستغرق شركه شيفرون عاما
على الاقل لبدء اعاده الانتاج انتاج النفط
الى 200,000 برميل يوميا في مشاريعها
المشتركه مع شركه النفط الفنزليه الحكوميه
اخيرا انتاج فنزويلا من النفط توقف عند
حوالي سبع مئه الف برميل يوميا هذا العام
انخفاضا من اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين يوميا في
تسعينيات القرن الماضيه